ja freue mich sehr auf diese Runde
überfällig finde ich gerade auch in
dieser Sendung wir haben so viel über
das Thema gemacht und freue mich auf
einen durchaus selbstkritischen Angang
dieses Themas er Lauterbach drei Jahre
Pandemie drei Jahre Einschränkungen seit
wann ist das Elend für Sie vorbei
zunächst die also Pandemie ist nicht
vorbei sondern wir gehen jetzt
zwischendurch
es ist eben so also wir gehen jetzt also
in dieses endemische Stadium über aber
der Drosten hat doch gesagt das vorbei
es äh also nicht alles also was da
draußen sagt stimme ich zu aber ist
meisterwohl das nicht vorbei nein wir
sind doch nach wie vor also
es sind doch nach wie vor Menschen
schwer erkrankt haben wir haben jeden
Tag Infektionen die also Fälle gehen
zurück aber sie sind immer noch daher
also ist es immer noch ein guter Rat
vorsichtig zu sein besonders wohl eine
Rabe Gruppen zu schützen zum Beispiel
Menschen in Einrichtungen sind oder die
in Krankenhäusern sind wir sind in
Deutschland vorsichtiger gewesen als
andere europäische Länder haben daher
aber auch eine geringere Sterblichkeit
gehabt obwohl wir eine sehr alte
Bevölkerung haben und ein riesiges
Handicap wir haben also noch einen
zusatzhandik gehabt aber wenn dann
vergleicht also sind mit weniger Toten
als England Frankreich Portugal Spanien
Italien Deutschland genau und das obwohl
wir sehr alte Menschen haben in
Deutschland und das sonderproblem hatten
dass also durch eine seiner
querdenkerfront die sich aufgebaut hat
die Impfungen bei älteren Menschen nie
so weit und ausgebreitet werden konnten
wie notwendig gewesen wäre da haben wir
große Handicaps gehabt gemessen daran
sind wir bisher gut durchgekommen
[Musik]
bis auf Krankenhäuser Arztpraxen
Pflegeheime gibt's ja seit der
vergangenen Woche keine Maßnahmen mehr
ne wie Unrecht lassen sie seitdem die
fahrzahlen sind runtergegangen und die
Maßnahmen sind ja zurückgenommen worden
auch von mir in der Funktion als
Bundesgesundheitsministers kann man
jetzt ohne Wenn und Aber vertreten aber
also atmet schon schwer ja das kann man
das ohne Wenn und Aber vertreten und wir
haben es halt lange also so gemacht dass
wir so regeln hatten wir haben zum
Beispiel auch im letzten Herbst sehr gut
die Pflegeeinrichtungen geschützt und
auch die Krankenkasse das sind aber
trotzdem pro Tag um die 100 Menschen bis
150 Menschen an Corona gestorben okay
dann noch eine ganz kurze frage nur weil
ich mich wirklich interessiert die
Kollegen der Zeit berichten am RKI
herrscht immer noch strenge
maskenpflicht
wir haben auch im BMG maskenpflicht bei
ihnen im Ministerium wir tragen weiter
Maske das wird irgendwann wird das also
aufhören aber warum darf ich fragen
warum ja zunächst einmal also müssen
Mitarbeiter des
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums besser
geschützt werden als der Rest der
Bevölkerung nein es wäre die böse es
wäre die böse Interpretation aber
Gesundheitsministerium macht ja keine
Operation am offenen Herzen das ist
richtig das ist absolut richtig aber
also zunächst einmal haben wir ja eine
gewisse Vorbildfunktion aber zum zweiten
ist auch so weil wir die Masken getragen
haben jetzt auch in den letzten Monaten
im Haus also und das ist relativ strickt
auch eingehalten worden haben hat also
tatsächlich sich viel weniger
Leistungsträger in unserem Ministerium
die haben sich infiziert wir hatten
weniger Ausfälle wir konnten also wir
konnten gute die Arbeit also durchführen
das ist ein Schutz der Beschäftigung und
auch ein Schutz wo wir uns gegenseitiges
haben so und weil wir heute über
Aufarbeitung sprechen und ich habe
gerade einen sehr namhaften Virologen
zitiert der sagt das Ding ist zu Ende
frag mal ganz offen in die Runde wenn
Sie das so hören
das klingt immer noch so als hätten wir
echt das Problem verhandeln
anders ich sehe es völlig anders und
wenn sie sagen
wir machen ja keine Operation am offenen
Herzen ich finde wir haben in den
letzten drei Jahren am offenen Herzen
das heißt Staats am offenen Herzen der
Demokratie operiert ich muss sagen mein
Fazit nach drei Jahren Corona ist
folgendes mir war dieser Staat der mein
Staat ist der unser Staat ist nie so
fremd wie in dieser Zeit er war
unbarmherzig und der ist mir manchmal
unheimlich erschienen in der Art und
Weise wir auftrat und es gilt für die
Exekutive für die Legislative und für
die Judikative für die Exekutive gilt
das deswegen weil also Polizei und und
alle die so ganz Verwaltung haben mit
einem Reglement sondern das gleichen mit
einer Kaskade von von Richtlinien von
Verordnungen die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
mit Alltags Regel überzogen hat die
teilweise richtig und zum großen Teil
falsch waren
in einer Rigidität darf ich nur ganz
kurz sie reden bitte weiter vielleicht
kann die Kollegen aus der
regiemonographische Bilder möchte ich
fast sagen war zuspielen Hamburg Jenisch
Park berühmter Park hier in Hamburg
diese Bilder wurden wenig später
deutschlandweit bekannt die Jugendliche
die sich glaube ich zu viert oder fünf
getroffen haben auf jeden Fall zu viele
und dann passierte das ist das was sie
meint vom Polizeiauto gejagt es ist auch
dieses passierte nicht nur in Hamburg
passiert ja auch in München den anderen
Städten aber es geht nicht bloß um
dieses Szenen es geht um das gesamte
Bild der Verbote der der
Sperren der Art und Weise wie die
Menschen in ihren Wohnungen festgehalten
wurden Ausgang sperren Reise sperren
dann die lockdowns die in der ersten
Phase ich tatsächlich goutiere weil man
noch nicht wusste wie es was da kommt
was kommt und wir es weitergeht aber
dann aber dann
es war ein regelungsexzess und es war ja
außerhalb von Gefängnissen ist in diesem
Land
in der Bundesrepublik das Leben nie so
reglementiert worden wie in diesen drei
Jahren und es war ein Exzess besonders
gleichen das werfe ich der Verwaltung
vor der Legislative werfe ich vor wenn
ich sage es war nicht mein Staat in der
Zeit mit dem ich noch konform gegen da
Legislative werfe ich vor dass sie sich
weitgehend zurückgezogen hat aus dem
Geschäft dass sie den Löffel abgegeben
hat und in der Verwaltung übergeben hat
und der Judikative Namen richtig den
Bundesverfassungsgericht werfe ich vor
dass es bei der Verhältnis bei der
Verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung unglaublich
zurückhaltend war wir haben vorher schon
angesprochen was in Pflegeheimen was in
den Krankenhäusern
wir es ist immer wieder gesagt worden
ihr Vorgänger hat sich dafür schon
entschuldigt oder gesagt dass man sich
viel wird verzeihen müssen es ist Zeit
für dieses verzeihen aber für ganz viele
Menschen ist es zu spät und
der oberste Satz unseres Grundgesetzes
der Ausgangssatz die Würde des Menschen
ist unantastbar wir werden im nächsten
Jahr das 75-jährige Jubiläum des
Grundgesetzes feiern wir haben hier ganz
viel verletzt wir haben ihn mit Füßen
getreten haben angefangen aus nicht
wissen und weil man es nicht besser
wusste später
viel nicht
richtige erforscht wurde weil man
bei einer Art und Weise wie man Experten
zugezogen hat viel zu schmal
nur Einsatz bitte dann
also wenn man also sie so reden hört
also es wäre vielleicht ausgangsleiter
im also wenn wir die Maßnahmen nicht
gemacht hätten also den Lockdown und die
kontaktbeschränkungen und das was also
gemacht worden ist dann werden sie
einfach laufen lassen den Vorschlag gab
es ja auch es gab zum Beispiel
Wissenschaftler die gesagt haben man
muss das Durchlaufen durch solche dann
wären in Deutschland ungefähr eine
Million Menschen gestorben angerufen hat
das kann doch nicht richtig sein
wie viele Menschen sind bis heute in
Deutschland dann Corona gestorben
ungefähr 180.000 okay
ich würde mal folgendes sagen also wir
haben also das ist keine schlechte Zahl
aber wir werden noch besser gewesen wenn
es nicht also diese ständige
Politisierung der Maßnahmen gegeben
hätte im Sinne Querdenker
Wissenschaftler sagen das ist alles
nicht okay gefährlich dass du gefährlich
wie eine Grippe und so weiter und so
fort dann wären wir noch besser
durchgekommen
doch sie mit dran schuld dass es die
Querdenker gab in der Art und Weise wie
sie Kritik abgebügelt haben wie sie
anders denkende als
Verschwörungstheoretiker bezeichnet
haben ich wenn ich sage das war nicht
mein Staat den ich hier erlebt habe
betrifft es auch die Art und Weise wie
ich mit anderen Meinungen mit
Andersdenken dann umgegangen bin und sie
haben letztendlich in der Art und Weise
wie sie ich sag's jetzt absichtlicher
Lauterbach wie sie hysterisiert haben
haben sie die querdenkerei mit
großgezogen die dekodiere ich richtig
werden aber die quer Denkerei ist auch
eine Reaktion auf die Art und Weise wie
die Politik ergeben natürlich ein
saftiger Vorwurf ne das vor allen Dingen
dann halt los hervorruft weil wir haben
die Daten ausgewertet und haben gesagt
also das ist die Situation ich bringe
ein Beispiel
die Frage war müssen die Schulen
geschossen werden oder nicht das hängt
davon ab sind die Kinder auch anstecken
und die Studienlage war so auseinander
sind auch an darüber lass uns dieses
Thema
sprechen das ist eine der ganz normalen
das undeutet dass das jetzt diejenigen
die versucht haben die Bevölkerung zu
schützen auch ältere Menschen und das
gemacht haben im Einklang mit der
Wissenschaft dass die jetzt plötzlich
verantwortlich gemacht werden für die
Querdenker das ist perfede und nicht
richtig und das ist auch deshalb
bedeutsam weil wir werden erneut
Pandemien haben und dann werden solche
Argumente wie sie ist jetzt vortragen
dass man den Eindruck hat werden das
alles gar nicht gebraucht das ist Gift
ich sage nicht dass alles nicht
gebraucht hätte einen großen Teil oder
großen Teil jetzt nicht gebraucht und
von der gesprochen
also sie sind Jurist als ein Jurist den
ich sehr schätze aber also ein der
Vorwurf hat die Wissenschaftler die
damals quasi die Beratung der Regierung
gemacht haben und auch die Politik die
wissenschaftlich gearbeitet haben wir
sind wirklich nach besten Wissen und
Gewissen vorgegangen und die haben nie
übertrieben sondern haben beschrieben
was Sache ist der erste Teil ist ganz
sicher richtig nach bestem Wissen und
Gewissen ob wir nie übertrieben haben
darüber sollten wir gleich mal sprechen
und die Wissenschaft ist ein bisschen
breit genau
ausholte warum die Frage ist doch wo
vermuten wir die Kompetenzen und wie gut
sind wir auch in der Peripherie
außerhalb der Regierung
fällt mit zu denken und da muss ich
schon sagen da habe ich schon sehr
gestaunt weil ich glaube gerade wenn es
um respiratorische Infektionskrankheiten
geht
nicht beschreibe jetzt nicht den Anfang
der Pandemie da wurden wir alle
überrascht das war für uns alle Neuland
da waren wir sehr froh um eine guideline
auch von von der Regierung her aber zu
einem gewissen Zeitpunkt
muss ich sagen es wäre gut gewesen wir
hätten auch selbst mitdenken und handeln
dürfen nämlich in unserem eigenen Kosmos
in unserem Fall Kosmos Kinderkrankenhaus
wir verstehen ganz ganz viel von
respiratorischen Infektionskrankheiten
das machen wir jeden Winter nämlich
nämlich durch also wir wissen wie gut
wir uns schützen können
wir dürfen bis heute nicht selbständig
regieren was wir machen welche Maßnahmen
wir ergreifen sondern wir müssen immer
noch Masken überall tragen und so bisher
was von Infektionskrankheit versteht man
als Pädiater wenn man lange im
Krankenhaus gearbeitet hat ich glaube da
hätten wir uns sehr früh ganz andere
Maßnahmen oder mehr Freiheiten gewünscht
mehr Freiheiten ja wie viel kann ich
selbst denken in meinem Mikrokosmos und
wir haben natürlich ein bisschen die
Möglichkeiten aus benutzt wir haben zum
Beispiel ganz früh begonnen ganz ganz
früh nach dem Lockdown begonnen und
haben gesagt wir können jetzt nicht die
Kinder nicht behandeln wir müssen das
aufdringlich setzen alles was irgendwie
möglich ist haben wir auf dringlich
gesetzt und dann trotzdem die Kinder
weiterbehandelt und auch die Eltern
übrigens konsequent mit aufgenommen ein
Elternteil das heißt mit anderen Worten
sie haben sozusagen Dinge gemacht die
sie eigentlich gar nicht hätten tun
dürfen
also dieses dieses übergriffige Momentum
das verbrannte beschreibt besteht ja
dann noch genau darin dass man doch in
Erfüllung seiner Pflicht etwas tut von
immer sagt ah eigentlich weiß ich das
ist eigentlich jetzt gerade nicht
regelkonform es ist kein gutes Gefühl es
war immer knapp Kriege konform
genau aber was wir jetzt bräuchten
werden Masken ab wir wissen wo wir die
Masken brauchen wir brauchen im
Krankenhaus nicht überall Masken das ist
nicht notwendig ich habe ein
sozialpädiatisches Zentrum das sind die
Kinder vor allem im und die Eltern im
Raum beim Behandler da brauche ich nicht
überall Masken
wir wissen wie es geht wir wissen jetzt
übrigens auch es ist auch nicht mehr der
gleiche Virus wie am Anfang da war es
tödlich der war gefährlich und er war
unbekannt jetzt ist ein Virus da wir
haben eine Immunität wir haben ja alle
durchgeimpft bei uns im Krankenhaus sind
alle geimpft alle haben eine Immunität
aufgebaut der Virus hat sich verändert
wir sind nicht mehr in gleichem Maße
gefährdet weil es sie sind sofort dran
weil wir dann gleich mal in dieses Thema
Schulschließungen ganz konkret noch mal
reingehen aber noch mal die Frage warum
machen wir das so warum darf sie nicht
einfach für sich entscheiden
Eigenverantwortlichkeit ist ja das Thema
und es wird auch gleich in der Sendung
noch mal eine Rolle spielen warum können
Fachleute dort nicht einfach entscheiden
wie sie es machen das klappt ja auch
sehr oft dass das dann freiwillig
gemacht wird aber es war sie müssen oder
sie dürfen
muss und sie möchte gerne ich habe gut
verstanden ich wollte nur das klappt ja
auch sehr oft das freiwillige aber es
klappt halt nicht immer und ich muss
halt die die Moment Stopp
wie es geht ja es ist aber trotzdem so
wenn das jetzt keine Verpflichtung wäre
dann würden von dem was wir beobachtet
haben halt an vielen Plätzen in den
alten in den Pflegeheimen oder in den
Kliniken die ffp2-masken nicht getragen
weil die sind natürlich auch sehr
unangenehm wenn man den ganzen Tag Tagen
muss und die die also würden dann also
typischerweise also an vielen Plätzen
nicht jetzt kann man sagen das ist nicht
so gefährlich weil
darum geht's nicht es geht um anderen
Punkt sie gestehen sozusagen gerade
einer Expertin einer Medizinerin nicht
zu dass sie selber beurteilen kann an
welchen Punkten
nicht das ist der Punkt das geht nicht
darum dass sie die gefährlich ist also
zunächst einmal ist es so dass also in
einem Krankenhaus nicht nur also
Expertinnen und Experten arbeiten
sondern da arbeiten sehr viele Menschen
Reinigungspersonal technische Kräfte
Leute die Beatmungsgeräte warten
bearbeiten Pflegekräfte
assistenzkräfte Ärzte auch somit also
wir um also tatsächlich in diese Phase
diesen Schutz zu beten der für Menschen
die zum Beispiel immun beeinträchtigt
sind wo dann tatsächlich auch die
ormicon Variante noch sehr gefährlich
ist haben wir das gemacht das wird man
nicht lange wird das so bleiben das wird
nicht mehr lange so bleiben weil die
Fallzahlen gehen herunter das hat uns
jetzt also in den Pflegeeinrichtungen im
Krankenhaus sind hat uns das sehr gut
gedehnt das hat wirklich wunderbar
geklappt und ich möchte mich da ja auch
bei all den Menschen in Krankenhäusern
arbeiten die das mitgemacht haben möchte
ich mich an dieser Stelle bedanke es
auch richtig weiß ich weiß dass ich weiß
was es bedeutet wenn man den gesamten
Tag über eine Polizei Maske wie lange
muss sie das noch machen das wird nicht
mehr lange so sein das werden wir also
mit den Ländern ich bin gerade mit den
Ländern also in Verhandlung auch wie es
mit bestimmten Maßnahmen die wir noch
haben weiter getesten beispielsweise
Masken aber ich bitte um verständlich
dass ich hier nicht selbst also eine ein
Datum ankündige das ist eine
Entscheidung die wir mit den Ländern
gemeinsam treffen und dann gehen wir aus
diesem Maßnahmen noch ganz kurz und dann
gehen
was uns mehr Freiheit und ihm auch
Gestaltungsspielraum gebracht hätte im
Nachhinein ist dass man uns Empfehlungen
aus dem aus dem Ämtern aus dem RKI gibt
an die wir uns an den wir uns
orientieren können wir dirigieren seit
dem
27.02.2020 haben wir eine task-kurs
eröffnet und seither die regieren wir
Corona für unsere gesamte Einrichtung
wir haben nicht nur Krankenhaus wir
haben Rehaklinik wir haben Kinderheim
wir sitzen zusammen und haben das
durchdregiert wir finden Empfehlungen
hervorragend da können wir uns daran
orientieren dass mitdenken durchdenken
wo brauchen wir was und ich glaube wir
haben im Land viele und vor allem in den
Krankenhäusern in Einrichtungen wirklich
viele kluge Köpfe die das auch
infektiologisch und auch in Ihrem
Netzwerk durch diskutieren und anfragen
sie dürfen alles was Sie wollen guck sie
nur an weil sie jemand sind der sich so
intensiv auch mit dem Thema beschäftigt
hat und bis einfach mal zunächst ganz
offen fragen wollte es geht Ihnen durch
den Kopf wenn sie das jetzt gerade zu
hören
gesagt hat einiges richtig also ich
würde den Vorwurf der Hysterie auch so
ehrlich sagen oder ich würde sagen dass
sie auch mit neu gewissen Rhetorik der
Angst gearbeitet haben und die nicht
immer
richtig war sie haben das ja gerade so
dargestellt also die richtigen die
echten die seriösen Wissenschaftler
immer die Hardcore Fraktion war und
alles die die anderen waren sozusagen
die nicht zu Wissenschaftler und ich
finde es gibt manche Beispiele wo sie
auch die Sache übertrieben haben mich
erinnere mich zum Beispiel an den april
2021 dann 20 21 dann haben sie noch mal
gesagt wir brauchen einen letzten harten
Lockdown sechs Wochen harter Lockdown
haben sie getwittert weil ansonsten
sterben in der Altersgruppe 40 bis 60
Jahre 10.000 Menschen haben sie getötet
es gab dann ein Lockdown und ich habe
jetzt mal beim RKI gefragt wie viel 40
bis 60-Jährige sind denn in dieser Zeit
gestorben und es waren halt nicht 10.000
es waren 700 und das heißt das zeigt für
mich sie haben sozusagen sie tun dann so
als ob sie immer auf Basis bester
wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnis
argumentieren und es war halt nicht so
sie haben halt oft mit Angst
argumentiert das ist der Twitter zu hier
ne diese Angst war und die Angst war
sozusagen nicht immer direkt und ich
finde es sowieso ein relativ schlechte
Art muss ich sagen zu kommunizierenden
Arzt nimmt Patienten eigentlich
unbegründete Ängste und ich finde auch
ein Politiker sollte nicht mit
Ängsten operieren und die möglicherweise
auf sehr wackeligen Beinen stehen und du
musst insgesamt bei der Pandemie glaube
ich immer unterscheiden über welchen
Zeitraum man redet ja also es ist halt
ein riesen Unterschied rede ich über den
März 2020
2021 oder 20 22 im März 2020 waren
Schulschließungen sicher gerechtfertigt
im März 2021 ist schon sehr fragwürdig
und im März 2022 werden sie vollkommen
unverantwortlich gewesen und insofern
kann man dieses Dinge nicht so ganz
pauschal Beurteilung muss sehr genau
schauen über welchen Zeitraum man
eigentlich schon muss ich aber auf den
Vorwurf reagieren können sonst also ist
es ja sehr einseitig dann also wird dass
sie erstmal in den Raum gestellt das
wäre damals also eine Berechnung gewesen
die hätte man so nie machen können Panik
also was auch immer da die also
Berechnung die ich damals vorgetragen
habe das waren Modellierung
Modellrechnungen und die meisten dieser
Modellrechnungen basierten auf
Berechnungen von Viola priesemann ich
einmal Hermann renommierten modellieren
ja aber das ist trotzdem es ist nicht
immer im übrigen aber ich sage nicht
immer aber nur vorsichtig das dann
tatsächlich die Situation sich in den
Frühjahrsmonaten deutlich entspannt hat
weil eine stärkere Saisonalität damals
aufgetreten ist als also in den Modellen
enthalten war das ist einfach eine gute
Entwicklung gewesen aber darum war die
Prognose nicht unseriös das war die
Prognose die die Modelle das sind
hochkomplexe Modelle einfach vorgegeben
hat das ist besser ausgekommen weil das
saisonalitätsfaktor der hat sich nachher
als stärker erwiesen bei omikon ist das
saisonalitätsfaktor weg das hat auch
niemand gerechnet es sind bei der Alpha
Variante zum Beispiel da hatten die
Modelle sogar die zusätzliche Ansteckung
unterschätzt dann also
Variante dann stärker ansteckend als
erwartet
werden so funktioniert Wissenschaft aber
dann zu sagen ihr zu habe ich hier eine
Überschätzung das hätte man so nicht
sagen können das ist nicht richtig wir
haben wirklich als also das waren
wissenschaftliches Team und übrigens es
sind da auch immer Dinge berücksichtigt
worden die also von Wissenschaftlern
vorgetragen werden die nicht dafür
bekannt sind dass sie sagt immer scharf
machen sind zum Beispiel in meinem
Corona
ich habe ihn selbst also mit aufgenommen
weil ich wollte dass wir auch jemanden
wie ihn dabei haben der Name
der zentralen Vorwürfe ist und das hat
der Brandl vorhin auch schon kurz ähm
einmal in in die Diskussion gebracht der
Gedanke waren wir oder die Frage waren
wir wirklich breit genug aufgestellt und
zwar bei denen auf die wir gehört haben
würden Sie sagen Herr Lauterbach mit der
bitte um kurze Antwort ja wir haben wir
haben wirklich auf immer auf die
richtige gehört oder waren wir im Fokus
eindeutig zu eng was gefehlt hat waren
Experten für die also Belange von
Kindern das ist im Nachhinein aus meiner
Sicht eine also
eine Einschränkung das war von Anfang an
also in diesen ursprünglichen
beratungsinsel im ersten Lockdown waren
die Teams also auf da waren gezogen
dabei aber nicht nur Virologen da waren
modellieren Modellierer waren dabei da
war eine sehr renommierte
sozialmedizinerin war mit an Bord
das also war schon mehr als Virologie
aber was gefehlt hat sind Spezialisten
gewesen für die Belange von Kindern
würden sie auch so sehen sie waren
keinesweg
Lauterbach orientiert sich sehr an den
modellieren das Leben spielt sich nicht
in Modellen ab sondern in der Schule
abgespielt sich zu Hause ab im
Homeoffice und hier haben sie einfach
nicht gesehen nicht nur was andere
Experten sagen die Leute von der Hälfte
von der Gesundheitsvorsorge
es wurden auch die Eltern nicht gehört
es wurden die die Schülerinnen und
Schüler nicht gehört das wurden die
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer zu wenig gehört
also wirklich die die vor Ort ihre
Maßnahmen aushalten
und leben müssen
es war wirklich die Expertise viel zu
schmal es waren eine
die interviewt werden nur sie sagen es
noch nicht Herr lauterbach
wie wir Demokratie am Anfang ja da
wussten wir nicht viel und da waren wir
froh wie gesagt da waren wir froh und
guidelines aber dann müssen wir wenn die
demokratischen Strukturen hinein und da
dürfen wir nicht einfach alles verbieten
da müssen wir Mitbestimmungsrechte haben
und das glaube ich das sollten wir
unbedingt wieder einfordern das sollten
wir für das nächste Mal gut lernen dass
wir die Mitbestimmung
ermöglichen und dass wir eben nicht
alles zentral dirigieren sondern lokal
die lokal denken lassen dann sind wir
ganz woanders dann hätten wir viel viel
früher wieder die Schulen geöffnet die
Kitas vielleicht gar nicht ganz
geschlossen andere Länder haben sonst ja
auch gemacht das ist das Stichwort weil
die einmal ganz kurz dazwischen darf zu
dem Thema und zur Frage wie breit sind
wir aufgestellt 3 dezember 2020 wir
haben auch hier in der Sendung auch
häufig wir beide auch über diesen damals
berühmten sozusagen schwedischen
Sonderweg gesprochen und es war immer so
dieses Raunen was passiert da eigentlich
was machen die Schweden da eigentlich
was machen die eigentlich anders und es
klang immer so wie das gelobte Land wo
sozusagen keiner gegängelt wurde mit dem
Tragen von Masken und so weiter und das
Leben ging einfach sozusagen schwedisch
entspannt weiter ich habe an diesem
dritten Dezember war unvorstellbar kalt
vor einer Klinik vor der vor der
carolinska in in Stockholm an der
stegnell getroffen den schwedischen
staatsepidemiologen der mir folgendes
sagte das war sehr interessant zum Thema
wie bereit stellen wir uns eigentlich
auf und auf welche Expertise Expertise
verlassen wir uns eigentlich bitteschön
befürchten sie nicht manchmal eines
Tages für die Todesopfer insbesondere in
den Altenheimen verantwortlich gemacht
zu werden
Leute dafür verantwortlich gemacht dass
sie ein ganzes Land in den Lockdown
schicken enorme wirtschaftliche Verluste
verursachen und verhindern dass Kinder
ihre Schulausbildung erhalten darüber
sprechen wir glaube ich viel zu wenig
das könnte man auch verurteilen wenn zu
viel getan wird
wir arbeiten sehr eng mit der Regierung
zusammen alle Entscheidungen werden
gemeinsam getroffen außerdem steht mit
75 80 Prozent die große Mehrheit der
schwedischen Bevölkerung hinter uns
ist also keine Entscheidung eines
einzelnen das ist Schweden
[Musik]
bis heute eine wirklich sehenswerte
Reportage wenn man da viel verstanden
hat von der Art und Weise wie die wie
die Schweden das Sehen in der Mediathek
auch noch zu sehen später dann erst im
März ausgestrahlt ich habe mir das heute
noch mal angesehen geführt am 3 Dezember
am selben Tag und es ist wirklich ein
ein Zufall am selben Tag haben Sie
folgendes getwittertal Lauterbach
Schweden zeigt wie verheerend falsche
wissenschaftliche Beratung in der
corona-politik sein kann technell ist
der Mann der mir gerade gesehen haben
lag fast immer falsch das sehr
selbstbewusst erstaunlich dass er noch
im Amt ist ein Ehren von Rücktritt hätte
ihm niemand vorgeworfen was haben Sie
heute dazu damals sind ja die
Todeszahlen in Schweden sehr hoch
gewesen und es ist tatsächlich so dass
in den Pflegeeinrichtungen sehr viele
Menschen gestorben sind viel mehr als
bei uns zum Teil war es so dass so gar
nicht erst so behandelt wurde also wenn
die dann Kranken diese Menschen hat man
diese älteren Menschen in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen sterben lassen man
hat sie nicht mehr in die Klinik
gebracht weil also der Versuch sie zu
behandeln nicht es war es nicht wert in
dem Sinne und sagt ja muss sagen
Verlust wenn man so vorgeht wie das
andere Länder machen so stellen und so
das wäre nicht der schwedische Weg
spricht auch entschuldigt auch über die
Kinder
bei den Kindern hat er ja recht also ich
habe eben schon gesagt und das ist wie
gesagt ich habe bei den Kindern als es
dann klar war wie es gehen könnte meine
eigene Tochter war ja auch betroffen
habe ich mich über verwechselunterricht
luftfederanlage etliche Male hier in der
Sendung und digitalunterricht ist okay
eingesetzt aber nochmal ja bei den
Kindern haben wir die lange schließen
das war ein riesen fehlt